Weeks after he announced his return as Superman,
Henry Cavill is out of a job – but at least
he seems to have gotten a hefty severance
package.
"Well that was fun, while it didn't last."
As the DC Extended Universe prepared to kick
off in 2013, fans learned that Henry Cavill
would be the next actor to portray Superman.
He made his debut via director Zack Snyder's
"Man of Steel," and for a few years, he continued
to feature prominently in the new cinematic
franchise.
However, in the wake of the disastrous 2017
release of "Justice League," he basically
disappeared from the DCEU spotlight, leading
many folks to wonder if they'd ever see him
don the cape consistently again or if Warner
Bros. wanted to take "The Man of Tomorrow"
in a new direction.
As speculation ran rampant, out of the blue,
Cavill got the chance to play Superman once more.
In 2022's "Black Adam," he appeared in an
additional scene to confront Teth-Adam himself,
seemingly promising a Black Adam-Superman
showdown sometime in the future.
Sadly, as we now know, this isn't going to
happen.
As the DC shared universe enters a reset period,
Cavill has been removed from the role of Superman
going forward.
This is arguably the best move for DC Studios
at this point, but it's just too bad his time
as Kal-El came to an end so unceremoniously.
"Oh see now that's cold, that's a betrayal.
I feel stung by that."
At the same time, one can't feel too bad for
Henry Cavill.
After all, he allegedly landed quite a hefty
payday for his brief "Black Adam" cameo.
"I have a second chance, Lo.
And I am not gonna waste it."
According to Umberto Gonzalez of The Wrap
on Twitter, Henry Cavill's incredibly short
Superman scene in "Black Adam" reportedly
lined his pockets quite nicely.
Gonzalez claims that Cavill scored around
$250,000 for his quick cameo, but that pales
in comparison to his payout as Geralt of Rivia
— a lead role he's also recently lost — for
Netflix's "The Witcher."
Cosmopolitan notes that for the first season,
he was paid roughly $400,000 per episode,
which was upped to over $1 million per episode
for Season 2.
Of course, one has to remember that these
numbers were for full episodes, not a scene
that clocked in under a minute.
Additionally, Gonzalez reveals that Cavill
was also paid for one other cameo in a yet-unreleased
DC Comics-based production.
The controversy-ridden "Flash" from director
Andy Muschietti supposedly included a cameo
by Cavill as Superman as well.
This is said to have netted him an additional
$250,000, bringing his recent DC pay up to
a staggering $500,000 in total.
However, unlike the "Black Adam" guest spot,
we more than likely won't get to see Cavill's
"Flash" appearance.
Reports indicate that the scene involving
him wound up on the cutting room floor, likely
due to his Superman departure.
"Well, I knew you didn't bring me back because
you liked me."
Based on these numbers, it's hard to dispute
that Superman has been an incredible moneymaker
for Henry Cavill over the years.
At the same time, one has to question if it
was ever truly about the money for him.
It's impossible to deny how much he adores
the character, as evidenced by his performances
and the way he's talked about it over the
past decade.
If you really want hard-hitting proof of his
love for Superman, though, look no further
than the Instagram post he made to announce
that his time as "The Man of Steel" had officially
come to an end.
In his emotional post, he wrote,
Time will tell who will be fortunate enough
to play Superman next, but they clearly have
some big shoes to fill.